what makes good notification it's a
great question so a lot of times when i
teach people about the hook model they
say okay i get the trigger phase right
we need to prompt people to action but
how do we make sure that we don't spam
people how do we know we're not sending
them too many of these triggers that
they become ineffective and there's
there's a secret here the secret is that
we have to closely couple the external
trigger the notification the message
that tells the user what to do with the
internal trigger the internal trigger is
this situation the emotion the routine
the place whatever it is that prompts
the user to act on their own accord so
the closer we can couple these two
things right the closer we can couple
the notification with the sensation or
the urge of oh this is what i need in my
day that's magic that's the difference
between magic and spam is context so
that's the key if you can closely couple
those two and that of course starts with
an examination doing a bit of a
narrative on your user to figure out
when are they most likely to need this
product throughout their day so don't
just willy-nilly send them notifications
all day long but couple those
notifications with a time and place when
your user is more most likely to
actually need the solution so there's
like a delightful moment and you couple
it with a notification right well it's
it's it's a moment when the user has
this need so for example let's say i'm
building uh a an app that plays music
right a music service or a news service
right a great time to couple that need
would be when i have the existing habit
of turning on my radio right so if you
could use geolocation or other data or
time of day data or appointment calendar
information something that the user can
tell you about about how they behave day
to day so that you can appropriately
target that trigger at the moment in
time where it feels like magic wow i was
just about to turn on my radio i think
i'll use this app instead